all right wedding season is here after
two years of the pandemic more couples
are going big now to tie the knot so
what are some of the big trends to
ensure a wedding that you will just
cherish forever keep those memories
alive joining us this morning celebrity
and bridal stylist michaela erlinger and
michaela first of all
you are a recent bride so not only have
we seen your styles on a variety of
different celebrities you yourself were
the celebrity for one day so i know this
was a long time coming though because
you were supposed to get married in 2020
so talk about that experience of waiting
because of the pandemic to have to walk
down the aisle
well i can relate to so many couples out
there i had to postpone three times but
took it in stride and was finally able
to celebrate with three days of parties
to make up for each one of those
postponements um it all worked out in
the end and it was you know it was it
was worth the wait let's talk about the
most important thing where it kind of
starts off and michaela that is the ring
what are the trends that uh we're seeing
for for engagement rings well i believe
that walking down the aisle is the
closest thing to walking on the red
carpet and i wanted to include and
design a collection that had a variety
of styles for every couple and every
bride out there so there are 16 styles
for her and for him and we exclusively
launched the collection originally in
platinum which is my favorite metal
the
the settings were
really delicate and very sparkly and
lots of hidden details and modern
timeless settings but as one of the
trends arose that we noticed
couples were looking for 18 karat yellow
gold and rose gold so we recently
expanded the collection to include those
additional medals you want a ring
to be something that you are going to
cherish it symbolizes your relationship
and is something that you're going to
treasure and wear every day
and what i love about de beers forever
mark is that not only are their diamonds
incredibly special and rare and very
sparkly
but they are also responsibly sourced
and i think that now more than ever
couples are really you know paying
attention to where their jewelry comes
from and the investment that they're
making and so this is something that you
can be proud to wear i would say jewelry
is a big trend um coming out of the
pandemic now more than ever and of
course big weddings are back so think
big wedding dresses think uh you know
lots of special details whether it's
gifting your bridal party um or gifting
the mother of the bride or father of the
bride with
special things that mean something to
you as a couple it's like that big
storybook wedding i mean seeing your
dress that big ball gown so so you're
kind of saying you know after two years
of having to take it easy now it's kind
of like go big or go home go as big as
you want
i like that and and really quick on the
rings i saw a lot of solitaires that
looked like a lot of round cuts is that
probably more popular now we actually
have a variety of different cut stones
we have everything from rounds to ovals
to emeralds to cushions and there is
something for everybody i encourage you
to check out t-bird jewels um here in
las vegas or of course forevermark.com
wonderful well again michaela
congratulations on your own wedding
photos looked beautiful
all about those forever moments that we
appreciate you getting all of our brides
here in las vegas ready have a great
morning